[Music]
okay so once again we are continuing to
play very fundamental openings
so e3 is called the
is called the calling what is there to
say about this this is a very solid
opening
but black doesn't change the way that
they play so we play knight f6 we
basically play queen's gambit decline
setup
regardless of how white puts his pieces
together
what do you mean
okay so c4
so here we've transposed to essentially
a queen's gambit
um with the movie three which is
relatively innocuous because it blocks
in the bishop but we don't change the
way that we play we play queen's gamut
decline here e6
yeah the kali actually is not c4 if y
wants to play the pure kali the move is
bishop d3 and i'll show the setup after
the game
knight c3 and
uh
once again we are putting
we are playing the the the qgd set up
bishop e7
castles all of the regular queen's
gambit decline moves yeah c6 is the slob
setup but we're blocking the bishop
along this diagonal but we can always
fianchetto it
um rarely does
uh rarely does this bishop experience
big problems okay so he goes before
what can we say about this this way of
playing well first of all what
immediately jumps out to me is that
white is not developing any of their
king side pieces at all like zero
and we already know that
the proper response to this kind of play
is usually to open up the center that
allows us to punish our opponent for not
developing now it's not that easy to
open the center here right because we
can't play c5 we can't play c5 because
white's
defending that square we also can't play
e5 i mean just d takes e5 we can play d
take c4 but that really helps white
develop right that helps white develop
their bishop
so we can play b6 to prepare c5 but
there is an even more effective way of
making c5 possible and that is to start
by undermining this b4 pawn
how do we undermine that pawn this is a
pretty typical move a typical response
to the move before and many different
openings that is the move a5
essentially forcing beef i mean white
can also take on a5 but that still
allows us to play c5 there's nothing i
guess so i can play rugby okay but
should be two just blunders the pawn
bishop b2 just blunders the pawn so we
take on b4
and then of course we need to take the
rook first because it's hanging and
we've solved our problem and one upon
i was hoping that he would go b5 for me
to demonstrate the path forward there
okay thank you for the pawn
and we are also ready to play c5 we we
can go knight e4 we have a nice pin
going here
white needs to be very careful not to
lose in just a couple of moves what our
opponent needs to do is start developing
asap on the king side otherwise we're
gonna go c5 open things up and just
crash through
okay
bishop a3 good move
that's a that's a very decent move
now i think most people's
instinct here would be to assume that
you have to trade but in fact we have
many ways of either trading on our own
terms
uh or
even potentially declining the trade so
who can propose a nice way of keeping
the tension here
yeah a paper
so i see two moves the first is to play
queen e7
and basically say okay i'm ready to
trade bishops but you're gonna have to
let our queen come to b4
uh we can certainly play knight c6 the
downside of that move
oh it looks like my stream is dropping
okay my stream drops some frames
um just refresh guys
knight c6 has the downside of blocking
the c5 uh the c7 pawn which i don't
really like
yeah sorry i think it's back now
i think it's back now
but
to continue my thought in my opinion the
best move here is to play c5
in my opinion the best move is to play
c5 because this move carries two ideas
if white takes which probably white
should do then we take with the c pawn
we have a nice passer
and we're attacking the knight so we're
continuing the initiative right
the question yeah so if d takes c5 this
seems like it poses
a pretty big challenge because now we've
given up the pawn we cannot take back
because white's bishop x-ray defends the
c5 pawn
but the move c5 and such openings
carries a very important benefit it
opens up a pathway for another one of
our pieces what am i talking about
what am i talking about i'm talking
about the move queen a5
now we're pinning the bishop
so bishop takes before loses the queen
in fact white's move is absolutely
forced and that is to bring the bishop
back to b2
and then we have a multi we have a
multitude of moves there he goes 92 that
blunders the bishop
and blender's the bishop
uh what do we want to take it with
well this is a great example of not
assuming that you need to trade pieces
because the king remains in the center
and because the bishop on f1 has a hard
time developing i propose we take with
the bishop
by keeping the queens on the board we
increase our chances of winning this
game quickly so now we still have this
attack and now we have an extra bishop
on top of it
does that make sense so you have to
resist the urge to always assume that
trading is the best path forward it's
not
okay what to do now king d1 it's just
total desperation
he's trying to unpin the knight i think
that much is clear
now uh the path forward is to open up
the center as quickly as possible this
king is stuck in the center
so
it's pretty clear that the d-file is
going to be our main avenue of attack
the d-file is currently closed
the simplest way to well queen takes c5
is possible but let's open it up by
playing d take c4
try to identify what and i always refer
to it this way the avenue of attacker
the main pathway of attack what i mean
by that is precisely the file or the
diagonal that's going to make the
you know it's going to be the main path
to your opponent's king
you cannot attack really without open
files 94 is a great move by the way
trying to close down the e-file now the
d-file
what now
well can the knight be kicked out that
should be our initial instinct can we
kick this knight yeah we can we can go
e5
very good we could have also started by
playing rook d8 that might have been
even more precise but this is perfectly
good enough we get the knight out of d4
and then we're going to go rook d8 check
and whatever happens i know that's going
to be good for us
now white can potentially force a queen
trait here if he's very accurate let's
see if he manages to do that yeah he
does
oh we have a cool move here
if we want to avoid the queen trade
which
i don't know if we necessarily do i
think even on the queen trade our attack
continues
but if we wanted to avoid the queen
trade what move could we have played
here
and it's fine we won't
yeah we could have brought the queen
back to d8 unpinning it from white's
queen and then taking the pawn of the
bishop but i knew he would play king c2
which is a bad move because it walks
right into another check which wins the
game
what to do now
now the best way of developing is
developing with check
the king is on c2 it's very vulnerable
and we give another check with the
bishop this is almost checkmate e4 is is
literally forced
and of course we have to understand that
our threats against white's king are so
much more
significant
than the fact that our bishop on a3 is
hanging yes it's hanging yes he can take
it of the queen but look at the attack
against white's king that completely
outweighs
that bishop on a3 our bishop is no
longer needed for the attack
of course we don't take on e4 with the
bishop that would be kind of dumb
because it would allow knight takes e4
um
we have to take on e4 with the knight
setting up a discovered a devastating
discover check
and if white trades then we take with
the bishop and it's essentially
checkmate
it's essentially checkmate
so white's days here are numbered
knight takes a three
okay so
here it's important to be accurate um
there is a move that i think some of you
guys might be tempted to make which is
quite a big inaccuracy
yeah so i see some of you saying it rook
d2 check very tempting move
a piece of advice for attacking is be
very careful about moves
that are made in close quarters with
your opponent's gang because the
situation could arise where you give a
check like rook d2
white moves the king back to c1 and all
of a sudden your knight on e4 is tied
down to the very rook that you just put
on d2 the king is a very pesky defender
so attacking from a distance is often
better than just putting a rook and your
bishop and your knight right next to
your opponent's king because those
pieces could actually start
could actually start getting loose if
that makes sense knight takes e3 is the
simplest move but re
wins back the extra piece opening up a
check on the king and it's made in a
couple of moves
okay
now
you know there's a very similar
checkmate in two
now rook d2 is good but still not the
most accurate
the most accurate of course is queen
before chuck
king c1 and then rook d1 mate
this is very easy
and a simple attack that includes
successfully
boom all right good game over 1100
okay a little postmortem
that was a simple game but i think an
instructive one
now the kali system named after ed
garcali who uh i believe was
i'm not sure what his nationality was i
want to say hungarian but
let me let me look this up
no belgian edgar collier belgian chess
master
1897-1932 very very strong player died
very young
but
introduced quite a bit of
influence into opening theory
so what i would compare the kali system
to is the london
uh the calling is like the london the
difference is that this bishop on c1 is
generally speaking fiancado rather than
put on f4 but there's a lot of
similarities
um so the pure la the pure kali is
bishop d3 in this position that's how
kali himself played it
and basically it's quite a symmetrical
opening you know black can play bishop
d6 here or bishop b7 both moves are fine
and generally what happens is that oops
nope not bishop f8 castles and now b3
and
white uh puts his other bishop on b2 and
the bishops are kind of i think they're
called co-linear bishops
um and
you know white then can play c4 it's
you can check my game with jeffrey zhang
at the us championship i i won a nice
game with a cauli against him
um and black is a gazillion different
setups black can play c5 black and
fianchetto his own bishop
black can do neither
so i don't want to delve too deeply into
the theory i'm sure we'll probably face
it again
okay
so dan r primos why not develop the the
light scored bishop i assume you mean
before playing e6 because i i think a
lot of people would find this
counter-intuitive
but the problem is that you don't have a
good spot to develop it to the only spot
to develop this bishop is g4 bishop g4
is a viable move
but what could end up happening here is
that this bishop gets pushed around like
white can go 92
and this bishop starts getting kind of
pushed around i'm not sure i'm not
convinced that it's that great on h5 but
bishop g4 is a legitimate legitimate
option
okay so bishop e7 castles castles or
sorry no no no that's not what happened
he went c4
ah much yes thank you e6
knight c3 bishop e7
and now he goes for this plan a3
um yeah c5 is fine c5 is a legitimate
move as well castle's in b4
so b6 here would be quite a good as well
b6 and c5 is
uh a typical plan
as well but but white could potentially
go c5 here and close everything down
and if you go a5
if you go a5
um
then
then white plays i don't think there was
a disconnection that might plays bishop
b2 and everything is fine white holds
this together
chris velos asks what if he pushed c5
here well if you push c5 here then we
take on b4
and the rook on a1 hangs so white
doesn't have time for this that's the
whole point that's sorry that's why we
need to play a5 so quickly
and if b5 then we go c5 when we open up
the center i'm not saying this is that
great for black but at least it's a good
way to try to punish him for
overextending his pawns
um queen a4
i guess is a way to stop atex before but
it's not going to end very well
queen on a4 like this is way too loose
uh black probably has many ways to play
here
um maybe just bishop d7
get the queen out of there and a b5 then
again we can go c5
i'd have to think about it but queen a4
is not a big danger yeah once bishop b2
is played the game is almost over we win
this pawn we get a pin
and then we very quickly play c5 this is
the most important move of the game
so what does this teach us when your
opponent offers a trade and you feel
like you have an initiative
always try to find ways to trade on your
own terms by that i mean
you can you can trade or you can decline
the trade but there is this middle
ground where you say okay i'm willing to
trade but you're going to have to give
me something for that trade either a
past pawn um and you'll often see if we
had an a pawn we might have gone a5 as
well
there's many opening variations that
build precisely on that idea for
instance even in the bogo indian defense
after bishop d2 one of the most common
moves here is either a5 or c5 or queen
e7 all of which are examples of trading
on your own terms
okay
um
okay so there should be two takes take
take stakes then we go c5
dc5 and queen a5 another very typical
idea you see this in the grunfeld
sometimes as well
you might ask how do i know about this
idea well in the grunfeld this c5 and
queen a5 idea recurs quite frequently
um
and and that's one of the ways that i
know ideas like when you have a lot of
experience in chess you know a lot of
different openings and these openings
teach you different ideas so for
instance of the grunfeld
black's main continuation here is c5 dc5
and queen a5
creating a pin and threatening knight e4
okay so back to the game
bishop a3 c5 takes queen a5 okay this
blunders a piece and then the game ends
quickly white's only move was bishop b2
but then after queen takes e5 the
position remains
basically losing because we're
threatening to win a second pawn
and if white takes on d5 then this is
totally totally crushing
okay so that's uh simple enough
simple enough and this shows how to
punish early queenside play without
development thank you general lilnept
and
what i want to add as we transition back
into blitz is that
i think this is a very underestimated
way of studying chess people only want
to look at games within their opening
repertoire don't do that
try to expose yourself to games in many
different openings not only does it
educate you generally but you learn all
these new ideas and
you know
you become more comfortable in case you
decide to play a different opening
and and you also just you can borrow
ideas that's completely a legitimate
thing we saw that here
borrowing ideas from one
line to another
is
you know from one opening to another
enriches your play and allows you to
figure out how to play in unfamiliar
positions
[Music]